estas nuevas decisiones estas
restricciones para todo inglaterra que
comenzarán a partir de la próxima semana
significa que durante cuatro semanas los
negocios van a estar cerrados sobre
todos aquellos que no son esenciales
como pops y restaurantes también como
gimnasios además la diferencia es muy
importante destacar a diferencia del
confinamiento nacional del mes de marzo
las escuelas y las universidades
permanecerán abiertas para todos los
alumnos este anuncio de boris johnson se
hace exclusivamente para inglaterra
porque escocia irlanda del norte y gales
toman sus propias decisiones como
regiones autónomas
escocia la próxima semana tomará su
propia decisión de cinco niveles
dependiendo la región pero seguramente a
raíz de este anuncio del primer ministro
boris johnson no sería sorprendente que
escocia siguiera exactamente los mismo
pasos y hay que recordar que el nivel de
infecciones es tan alto que los
consejeros médico y científico del
primer ministro británico decidieron que
este confinamiento tenía que ser
necesario para que no se sobrepase el
sistema de salud pública
en elche ya que hay cierto número de
camas de las unidades de cuidados
intensivos y de no hacerse este
confinamiento se podría ver sobrepasados
se podría haber rebasado